Hello everyone. Welcome to toxic Google.
I'm Kevin Valve with the Google team.
And here we are in sunny
la at youtube space.
So how awesome is this space going guys?
So this full productions facility,
we're really,
really excited here because we're doing
something brand new that we haven't done
them toxic Google before. We're
doing a youtube three 60 degree live.
So we're live right now across the world.
And these two cameras that
you see here are 360 degrees.
So for you guys watching online,
you probably have a great
shot in my pelvic area.
And so what we're going to be doing
here today is interviewing the cast to
finding dory. So we're gonna bring
him up here in just a second.
So if you guys watching online,
if you're watching on your mobile device,
just take your phone,
just look around and complete 360 degrees.
Then we got some fun
stuff here in the back.
You can look around the production
facility, um, and then four,
if you're on desktop, just take your
mouse, click the video, move it around,
and that's it. So. All right,
we're going to meet the cast.
It's bring him out,
ladies and gentlemen,
the cast, the voice cast and creative
team behind Disney. Pixar is finding dory.
Ready? Welcome guys. Thanks
so much for coming here.
Um, so, uh, finding dory out June 17.
Thank you guys all for being
here. Uh, Ellen, welcome. Uh, so,
uh,
this is a movie completely about your
character Dory and you've been characters,
right? Uh, thank you. Uh, and uh,
but so York, yeah, go ahead. Out.
I'm dory.
Okay.
And so, but you were huge cheerleader
for this film for years on your,
uh,
on your show.
Thank God I had a show. We would not be
sitting here had I not had a talk show. So
talk about
to intimidation. Yeah. He finally called
and said, uncle, he's like a, all right,
we'll do it. Let's do it. It was this, you
said, I was just kidding. I was like, no,
I'm not interested. No, it
was a, it was started. Is,
is I seriously wanted a sequel.
I was like,
they make SQLs for every
other successful film.
We won an academy award for crying
out loud. So where's the SQL?
And then it just got to be a joke and
then I just gave up and I was just, well,
I'm just going to keep going because it's
funny. But uh, and then it worked out
and then 13 years later, so Andrea,
you brought this back 13 years later.
So when did that idea,
I want to push it again when you make
these movies that you see them so many
times. So I'd seen finding Nemo about a
hundred times before 2003 even finished.
So he just stop watching.
And about eight years later,
it was 2011 they wanted to put it out in
three d they put me in a theater and I
watched it like an audience member
for the first time in a long time.
And I walked out so worried about dory.
I was just like,
she's going to forget Marla Nimo.
She won't know how to get back
and I don't know where she's from.
And I think that yes, she's
got abandonment issues that
I know about as a writer.
So it like suddenly it was just all, it
just all started to bubble up after that.
It's, it's unbelievable. And it's, it's
wonderful thing. I've seen it. It's, it's
otherwise, as long as you're here,
you make the third one before we die.
Oh, okay. Oh well I want,
I want to get to you actually about your
character to Marlin Marlin's back. Um,
and we have the new voice of Nimmo
birthday up there. Hayden. Hey,
say hello to everyone.
Hayden Hayden's
actually 30
plays a really good nine year old,
like you guys didn't know yet.
And so l a Alberta,
your character Marlin is back obviously.
And it's interesting cause it was really,
really great to see you now have a
completely different dynamic with your son
Nemo.
And now Marlon is much more particular
dory who wants to go find your family.
So can you talk a little bit about
where Merryn is at the stage and,
well,
I know he doesn't agree,
but I thought that Marlin
was in love with Dory. Okay.
I mean it, I just figured that, you know,
whatever makes the seats were heard.
Marlin's lonely and, and, uh,
you hadn't found anyone else and
she's lovely and you know, why not?
But, uh, I think we have the next
seat and say there's your third.
Um, but you know, it was
great. I Hayden's terrific.
Alexandra Gould who played the first one,
he's 42.
I actually was in weeds
with him after he was Nima.
Roy played his grandfather in weeds,
so that was sort of interesting.
Talking about pot with Nemo,
you know,
but a Hayden's wonderful and you
know, like a modern, divorced family.
Here's the new kid.
There we go. It's gone.
Great. Uh, so ty and Katelyn,
you guys play new characters in
the film. So we have, uh, Bailey,
which is your character
tigh and then designate.
So tell us about your characters.
Um, we're buddies. Yeah. Uh,
basically, uh, Bailey and destiny are, uh,
two people that Dorian lists
to help her find her folks.
People.
There are two people dressed in
whale and whale shark costumes.
It's like an abstract kind of a thing
we were doing. Did you dress in wheel
costumes when you recorded this?
Didn't need to do for the only
line moving. It was exhausting.
It has been so hot. It's really hot. Yeah.
You're Bailey's a big Beluga whale and
a destiny is a giant whale shark and
they're kind of a brother,
sister relationship and they
get on each other's nerves,
but they're very sweet and they ended
up, uh, trying to help dory out.
Great.
And we have an exclusive clip we're going
to play here in just a few minutes, uh,
with your two characters. So what,
bring that up here in a little bit. Um,
but Ellen, so you know, you're returning
to the character of Dory. It's a really,
really emotional story about her trying
to find her parents. So, um, you know,
when you first read the script,
was there anything that you were able
to bring to the scripts or tell Andrew,
I'm looking for this and the character,
I want to go this direction?
Um, no, I, I mean, this
guy is a genius. This, I,
I'm not going to tell him how
to write a script. Um, I mean,
when I was in the room I
changed a lot. But I, yeah,
no,
but you know, that's what's great
about it. The script is fantastic.
The script is what it is, but it's,
it's open and free enough that you do,
you know,
50 takes and,
and you can then he did you just do
whatever you want to do and he chooses,
they choose whatever it
turns out to be the best one.
So it's always the first.
But you know, it's four years writing
this thing. I mean, so we're doing,
but there was over 10 drafts of
this story done over that time.
And they know that what we're working
with them and you also adapt to the actors
once their cast. So
you're, you're, you know,
I'm learning just as much from them
and we're rewriting to play to their
strengths so that it's like hopefully
comfortable shoes almost. And they, and,
and you just, it becomes a little
symbiotic at a point. And Eugene,
you play Charlie. Yes, that's
correct. Other of Dory. Yeah.
So what can you tell us
about Charlie and oh,
well it was a,
it was exciting to play a,
a dad who has a child not
doing strange things with pies.
Uh,
that was a big plus.
Okay.
That was me.
That was like your first question in the
yeah,
write that out.
Does dory eat baked goods?
No.
Uh,
no. It was kind of a, it was a
very charming, well, I was just,
I was honored to be included in this
thing and no question about that.
And playing a dad, uh, you know,
uh, have a child who is, you know,
kind of memory impaired so to speak.
So there, you know, there it's a,
it's kind of a very funny,
very amusing and,
and there's something very heartfelt
about playing, um, you know, a dad,
um, where, whose child is off somewhere.
You don't know what happened and you know,
will they ever be able to,
you know,
how will they function
because she has no memory,
a short term memory.
So, you know, um, it's,
uh, it was interesting and
complicated and fun and exciting.
I mean,
that's a real powerful part.
Two and hit it and I'll get right
back to you. But Andrew and Lindsey,
when you're creating this story about you,
you,
it's very much of a comedic effect in,
um,
in finding nemo where you have Doris
character with short term memory loss,
but it's a real disability in,
in life and you really,
really hit it home in this
film. So was that, I mean,
cause she's really struggling with it.
You see in the beginning of
the film you see it throughout.
So was that a point that you really
wanted to drive home and yeah.
Well she's the main character.
Once you have a main character,
it has to be more depth to them and they,
and you sadly are sort of forced into a
bit of a straight man role when you were
in the main character will the thing
that it was always great about Doerries
that I always knew that tragic
side of her, that was always, uh,
I always knew her optimism
and her caregiving and her
candy spirit with somewhat
her armor to protect herself
from the sense of loss she had.
So it was just sort of
flipping that on this film.
It was, it was great too, because
I remember the day that you, uh,
there was this the scene where I had to
explain what short term memory loss was
and how to explain it.
And that was one of the Times that
I could just go and talk about what,
what to,
how to explain it to someone was hurt.
I mean, it was funny and
heartbreaking at the same time.
And I think that's kind of what the
movie really leans into on this one that
it's like it's charming and, and that
is dory and we kind of, you know,
we were always trying to walk that line
between the charm that was dory and that
is Ellen. And then also the, you know,
the kind of tragedy really of it and,
and making sure that we never lean too,
too far one way or the other,
so that we felt like it was being
really true to this character.
No, it was a delicate balance. I mean,
that's what it was like in the beginning.
The movie, you first, your
initial reaction is to laugh.
It's like, oh, that story.
And then it starts getting deeper and
you're like, Oh God, I don't like, it's,
it's really, really intense. So, uh,
Hayden, the new voice and Nimo, um,
pretty exciting from my
hometown of Chicago. So
welcome here to California. Um,
so what's it like to be an email?
Um, uh, it's very fun being
able to pretend that I'm
just a cute little fishing.
I'm not, yes. And I'm not just me.
I actually get to pretend that I'm
something that's a very good idea and very
fun to do.
Yeah, no, it's your were wonderful
in it. It's crazy. Cause I was,
when I was watching it and I actually
didn't realize the first one,
the trailers that they got a new voice,
I was like,
well of course it is
13 years later and you,
you pull your sounded exactly like
them. It's it, it's great. Yeah.
He's like the Darren of bewitched,
you know,
like he had to show your folks watch
original Darren and it's really tough.
And so a lot of this takes place in,
which is a great thing because
you can finding an email,
you'll see the characters going through
open water and oceans and everything,
and you have different apartments.
But now you're in a marine institute and
it's so for you, you, Lindsey and Andrew,
when you guys were there,
there's a lot of creative ways of how
the characters get around the park.
But what one of the most complicated
scenes as a producer, Lindsay,
you're just like,
really?
Honestly that was the,
it was when Andrew came and was like,
so we've come up with this new
character and he's an octopus.
And I said, I'm sorry, what? And he said,
he's an octopus boy. He's a step to posts.
So you get one less technical.
He is a Hank the octopus,
no doubt is the hardest character.
I think anybody at Pixar has ever
done and took two years. I mean,
normally our characters take kind
of nine months start to finish.
And this took two and a, he took two and
a half years just to build and rig. Um,
and so that was one where I was like,
really? Does it have to be an octopus?
Could you maybe not? Maybe turtle? No,
already have that now the front plastic,
the first shot took six
months to anime and we're,
we're never going to get
finished at this rate.
But fortunately ready got
smarter and faster. Gotcha.
And what environments where some the most
complicated ones cause you see them in
pipes and
it's, it's actually, if
you watch finding Nemo,
you'll notice that there was
like only three shots I think,
where we allowed Andrew to put the
camera in the corner of the tank of the
dentist office.
And it's because of the reflection
refraction talking to people at Google and
youtube. So I feel like I'm in a
people, you understand me? Um, so it's,
and it's really hard. I mean, we,
we intentionally didn't do that because
the computer couldn't do it and we had
to direct it and fake it,
all the lighting.
And so the new renderer are actually
allowed us to do much, much more.
And we took do it everywhere.
We basically, he did it
everywhere. I'm like blue.
Yeah, every possible container has
glass and reflection in itself.
Gotcha. Um, and so, you
know, are there any,
you know what Andrew I loved was,
you know, I remember watching,
I'm a huge Pixar fan animation fan and
I love watching in the first one some of
the making of it and you
kind of tacked onto this, um,
flashback thing and the first finding
email where you want to do flashbacks and
kind of tell the story through that.
And it's a great plot device that you
used here throughout the movie as well to
kind of tell Doris story.
Um,
was that something you immediately
knew that you wanted to do?
That is an 11th hour idea that
saved our butts on this movie.
We came up with it last fall,
but a lot of people don't know Nima
didn't come together until the last six or
eight months. Um, like all the pieces
where there we just didn't happen.
It didn't have them lined.
Right.
And so I feel like this movie is in good
hands in a weird way because it did the
same pattern. Um, but
yeah, the first movie,
all that tragedy you see at
the beginning of finding Nemo,
all that loss was actually
flashbacks that were doled out.
And it just didn't work.
You didn't sympathize with Marlin.
But once we saw his tragedy at the front,
we moved it all the friends and something,
all the lines we'd always had played fine.
Everybody empathized with them.
Um, and then this was the reverse. We
have too much information at the front.
And then when we doled it out and made
it memories that Dory or she has and is
triggered, she goes, it became like
the inverse of the first movie in it.
And it just felt right.
And it was Jason Bourne.
You can take that into your own life.
Start every conversation
with your saddest.
It works.
And so now we're going to Q, a, uh,
exclusive clip here from finding dory.
So let's clear it up.
Can you please keep it down over there?
My head hurts that my neighbor,
he was brought in with a head injury.
I know you're talking about me.
Destinee uses echolocation but I've
overheard the doctor's time writing every
word you're saying about me.
What's echolocation? Well,
Bailey's head is supposed to put out a
call and the echo helps him find objects
far away.
I'll put,
apparently he's still healing now.
I know you're talking about me.
I really can't echo like I
have this conversation again.
I get my head very hard out there and
see how it's falling in his head is
supposed to be big. You're a Beluga. Yeah.
Yeah.
So ty and Katelyn, those are your guys'
characters. Uh, Bailey and destiny.
Did you guys record it altogether to get
some of the dynamic and Improv and we
did.
That was,
that was fun. We got to do two
or three together is, you know,
mostly you just in there by yourself
with these guys. Right. Again,
um,
but we got to do a couple together and
it was really fun because we're actors.
We're used to working with
these spies by the way,
are amazing and they're too
smart for us though. It's much.
I'm always looked on people. Yeah.
Yeah. She was looking for an idiot.
That's your phone one. That's
right. It makes me more comfortable.
It makes me feel smarter.
Um, yeah, that was actually,
that was new for me. I, I, I
haven't done a ton of animation,
but the chances to go in and
be in the room with, well,
Katelyn in particular who was so funny,
um,
it's all, you know, the whole
process is so collaborative.
Um, obviously we're not really
tinkering with any of the major writing,
but these guys were just so smart and
so much changes as you're doing it.
Um, the, when we were
able to do it together
really felt the freedom to play
around a little bit and see what else.
Yeah,
that's great. So we're
going to bring up our, uh,
one of our youtube top creators smoothing
to ask him questions that he got from
our social media, a social media
handles. So let's bring him up.
Hi, check, check. How's
it going guys? All right.
So we asked a lot of our
youtube subscribers and the
youtube people's out there
some questions and a lot of
them were coming toward you,
Andrew.
They want to know how
you go about selecting
voices for your movies.
Oh, well, you know,
everybody knows the term that the camera
loves them. They're very photogenic.
But I like to say there's a term
with a microphone. Loves them.
There are people that just have voices
that you can just hang a character on and
sitting in front of you. Or five
amazing example. Six, I'm sorry,
I can't count today. Six examples
was either the one you weren't yeah,
yeah, I wasn't thinking year. My
girlfriend is not loving. Sorry.
There's five people in front of, you
know, four, no, wait a minute. Say
One guy who just tries super hard,
a hard working guy, but it's true.
Like when you want it. Like I,
I was started out as an animator,
so I really recognize like when
you hear a voice that you just,
you can't help a project, a
character on, you can't help it.
Like want to see a acting
from out of, out of, out of,
out of a different
character. It, it's a it.
And so you end up with these
lists sometimes. Um, uh,
Ellen herself as somebody
I wasn't thinking of at the
time when I was really an
early days of riding on finding Nemo and
then I heard her off of the television
set and boom, you know, it, it's suddenly
matched. I'd been a fan of Albert's,
you know,
ever since I can remember watching going
to all of his movies and listening to
his comedy albums and sorry, just waiting
for the right role to fall for that.
And then Katelyn,
same thing.
I'd sort of been a fan of her voice
and tie and a hate and I discovered,
and Eugene of all these are people that
I've just been fans of hearing and I
just go, they would be perfect, but
you're just waiting for the right.
Okay.
Character that you're coming up with and
hope that somebody else hasn't grabbed
them before you do.
Okay.
What's the other thing too,
on Youtube?
A lot of us are one man production
teams and a lot of us do animations.
So there's a lot of people are
wondering how do we start off?
Anybody that wants to be involved with
animation, the process, just out the gate.
What would you recommend as far as
programs for anybody starting out? God,
I don't know. I mean I'm too
old now. I don't, I don't know.
I started out with Pencil and paper.
I still use pencil and paper.
I don't know if anybody
knows what that is.
But all of the school like
stone age stuff. Yeah.
All I can say is it's so easy. I mean,
now you can make a movie in your house.
Like, like I get to steal stuff
like when I did it, you know,
to like get them to get movies
made and my backyard stuff.
But so I'd just say like do it.
Do you grab whatever you can and do it.
Like there's nothing stopping
you. So just do it. Oh,
this is for the cast of all the new
characters. Excluding yourselves.
Who's your favorite
character in finding dory?
I'm a Hank fan is rude
and you can't choose.
You can't choose yourself to that
question. Can we move on to Shrek?
Yeah, that'd be good. I'm studio. Uh, I
mean this one was popping up a lot. Uh,
we can go on to, all right. What
about other animated Disney films,
if you could be,
and any of those other
animated Disney films,
or what movie would you want to be in?
I,
I'm a huge fan of all the Pixar movies
and particularly all of Andrew's movies.
I was a huge fan of Wally and all
the toys, stories, those are just,
I watched those before I had kids and
then I, my little boys love those movies.
So those are the ones that are always on.
And so when I got the call about this,
I was like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I
don't care what I'm playing, but yes,
whenever I'd like to get the candles
sticker go and beauty and the beast.
Nice.
Broadway Virgin. No, not matinees. What,
what about you hate in any
other movie, Aladdin, Lion King,
any of those that you'd want to be in?
Um, I don't really know if I'd want to
be in any other movie besides this one.
Yeah,
you're checking
Buenas Ellen,
what about you?
Uh, same answer. I would never,
this is the one I thought dory
was great in finding email.
I'm
joy
site out would have been
fun. I like joy that, uh,
I mean I'm very happy being dory.
Eugene. Anybody? No, I, I,
you know,
the thing of it is really these pictures,
all the pictures are animations
are so incredibly great that,
and the process is so much fun to do.
I mean,
I don't know if anybody really understands
exactly what you do when you're in a
studio, but it's really quite amazing.
And when you get to work with,
you know,
incredible,
incredibly talented
like genius people here,
uh, where are you kind of
just give a line and they,
as you're giving the line and
the in the, in the, in the scene,
they kind of know they're making changes
as they're going, try it this way,
try it this way. And it's all happening
in milliseconds and it's just like,
it's an incredibly exciting way to work
because I got to act with Diane Keaton.
So that's probably why he's on a high.
I know my wife isn't here today.
Um, yeah, so that was a, that was good.
That was kind of a fun too. But yeah,
I I, you know, I would say it's just,
it's a really fun way to
work doing animated films
and when the scripts and the
stories or as as exciting
as a finding dory,
then you know, you're, you consider
yourself very lucky. Okay, awesome.
That's all the time I have for you guys.
Uh, we have some crowd questions later,
but I'm going to toss it back here. Thanks
so much for your time guys. Thank you.
Nice teachers.
Thank you Suzy. So we're going
to take some audience questions.
I think they're going to start
lining up here. Um, here we go.
Yeah.
Hey, you hear me? Yeah, I kind of
want to ask a question of everyone,
but I'm going to focus on dory, so
don't be offended. It's all good.
You're all cool.
So my question to you is in finding dory,
when are the mantras for me was just
keep swimming, which is, I'm a plus size,
health and fitness motivators.
I help women like me starting
to engage with fitness.
So to me it's about the journey,
bracing the journey.
Just keep moving no matter what happens.
Just keep going.
Well loving who you are
in the body you're in.
So what I'd be curious to know is what
is your life lesson coming out of finding
dory?
Did you have that moment that just keeps
swimming moments that really stood out
to you? Um, well, my life is, that's my
motto as well. That's my motto, I think.
Okay. It's yours and I'm now
we'll share. So sorry to know,
steal it from you second law
suit. Oh, I'm aggressive.
Um, well it was, it was kind of like
my motto.
It wasn't completely my motto.
Okay.
Um,
because I think if anyone knows my story,
it is, I had to just keep swimming. I,
you know,
my life has been a lot of challenges and
a lot of the different curves and uh,
and uh, roadblocks. And so I
think that's a great, you know,
I didn't come up with
Jessica keep swimming,
but it has turned out to be something
that a lot of people can hold onto and use
in their life. And so I would say
that just everything I think is, I'm,
I am so blessed and lucky that that's
part of my character that I get to say
just keeps, keeps swimming for whoever
you are and whatever you're going through.
Well, thank you for that cause it's a big
life changer. So thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
Ready next.
Awesome.
Hello.
I just wanted to know what your favorite
aspect of working on this film has been,
whether it's recording, fleshing out
the story, promoting it, et Cetera,
of anyone you've had the big you've
had probably the most to from. Yeah.
Uh,
it's honestly,
working with the actors is probably my
favorite simply because they're sitting
in front of me. Um, no, it's,
it's actually because it's the one part
of this process over four years that's
spontaneous where you're actually doing
a lot of give and take in the moment and
you're kind of, you're in the now
and you're just reacting. And, uh,
I find that so exciting. I get very little
of it waking in an animated pictures,
so I'm pretty hungry for it when we do
these sessions. I know they're grueling,
they're long,
these guys stand around for four hours
and they're just on the whole time.
So they're basically
doing a one person show.
And a lot of them I know I've said
that it's the most tiring thing they do
simply because there's no breaks
built into it. And, um, but um,
it's, it's pretty invigorating.
It's pretty exciting
to me.
Hello, I'm Christina cal from
the channel back girls ball. Um,
this question is for everyone. A lot of
people in the audience, including myself,
are content creators here at Youtube.
And I just would like to ask you all
what advice you'd like to give us with
building our careers.
Get Super Lucky.
Okay.
It's weirdly lucky.
Oh,
that's a horrible advice.
Horrible advice.
Well,
someone asked a question earlier about
to Andrew about how do you animate
something and you know,
I would say the answer
is the same and match a story.
You start with that, you start,
you're a content creator,
so you don't start with the actors.
You don't start with the [inaudible],
you start with a story,
you start with the content.
And if you have a great story,
it can fit a hundred different
ways to tell it animation,
it can fit live action. So you
know, think of great stories,
just stories that you haven't heard.
I would say that's a basis to start with.
I would say authenticity.
I think whatever.
I think when you,
if something's happened to you in
the same thing that Albert's saying,
if you have a story, you're probably
not the only person with that story.
Whatever it is.
And sometimes the best stuff comes out
of the hardest stuff and the worst stuff
that you've gone through. So if
you've actually experienced something,
I don't think anybody should
hide any kind of truth.
So whatever you have witnessed
or experienced or gone through,
find a way to express that
and find a way to stay.
And I think people read truth and
authenticity and I think that's the most
important thing for establishing anything.
And even if you don't have something,
you must have a horrible uncle.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Hello.
Um,
so I know a lot of you have experienced
with Improv and just being quick on your
feet and I was wondering how much
room there was for improvisation.
It seems like a lot from what you've
been saying, but how that improvisation,
uh, affects the process and the final
product and how it might be different from
other animated films as
it was with finding dory.
Well, I don't Dunno, compared to other
animated films are, are different.
Some are the Simpsons that I've done.
The whole thing was Improv'd.
There's always a solid script here.
And the thing about Andrew is
that once she gets those words,
if you're willing to keep going,
he'll take every word in the English
language out of you. So you know,
by the end of the day you've
given a lot of choices.
Hopefully there's some choices he
didn't think of and then they have to,
the thing I'm most grateful for is
I don't have to listen back to these
recording sessions
cause after 9,000 takes,
I just took you chew
every, every person here. There's at
least one or two lines if not more,
that are in the finished movie of things
that they came up with on the set that
I would have never written.
So,
but you know,
it's generally an animated films I think
generally welcome because it's at the
stage where it's still,
you're not coming into a finished movie
where you have to fit the exact words in
a mouth. So they generally, if
you can do it, they welcome it.
All right.
Thank you so much.
This is a question for Ellen and Dory.
How did you learn to speak?
Well, that's very good. First of all, um,
I was in Hawaii and there was a woman
who was staying in the house next to the
House that I was renting and she was
doing yoga and like crazy yoga on rocks
and, um, and listening
to whale sounds like,
I didn't know you could buy that record,
but there's a record that
just is whale sounds. And uh,
and I was listening to it and I just,
it just was like the most,
it was the weirdest thing
I'd ever seen in my life.
And I just thought a wave is
going to take her out any minute.
And it didn't kind of wanted it to
happen because it was just so weird that
she's on her head on a
rock. And, um, so anyway,
I just knew what a whale's
sounded like. And so, uh,
I didn't think I'd ever need
to use it in life, but I did.
I was so scared to ask her this.
I thought this is going to be the thing.
This is going to be the sub Nima. This
isn't gonna be the thing that makes me go,
okay, I'm done. I'm not in this
movie anymore. I'm out. And I'm like,
would you be willing to speak well?
And she told me this whole story right
away and then just went right into it.
Oh, I can speak whale. All right.
I've been waiting. Yeah. So that's it.
And it's a, it's not easy. I
mean, you did it very well,
but if you have to do it a lot, it's very,
uh, it's, it's tough on your vocal cords.
You have to kind of warm up.
Caitlin had to do it a lot
because her care characters,
the reason dory knows how to speak well.
So
yeah, it did it a lot. They'd look
at me and go, um, one last thing.
Okay, let's just do it. Give me some tea.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Hello.
My question is for Ellen.
What was the craziest moment that have
been onset when recording the movie,
Finding Dory?
Uh, the craziest moment. I don't know
if there was a crazy moment, but uh,
yeah, when your back went out you
couldn't even stay at your back.
Well, I don't even remember that
we didn't give it to the senior.
So what happened like this stand
up right before you came in,
do like a four hour session with us
and we were like, we're really sorry.
Could you do one more?
That's right. That's, well it's, I don't
know. It was crazy. It was sad. Sad, sad.
One of the saddest. Do you want a
sad moment are crazy. Yeah. I forgot.
And then I literally, I had to still do
it time. I got in that horrible accident.
Yeah, I remember that time
when I was so crazy. Crazy.
Crazy. Ellen. Yeah. Um,
I was going to say a,
this is just an excuse to
complain about it, um, that they,
because dory is always either left
behind or catching up to people.
So there's a lot of hyperventilating
like breathing really just,
you know, it's that or it's
like scream like a lot of those.
And you'd think that once,
I just did that,
you could use that throughout
the whole film. Right.
But I had to do it all the time. I
had to like in a just like, do you,
don't you really have the already,
so there was a lot of that.
And when you see this film and
you should see it many times, um,
you, you will see that I don't do it that
often in the film. And I don't know why
that was like your first comment that
was like, that was like Ellen was like,
I really loved it. Where was all
the gasping and paper ventilating?
Like literally that was
her first question. Yeah.
Like where is it? So it's in
the toys. Yeah. Yeah. I see.
That's how they get ya.
Thank you. Thanks. Okay.
Hello. Hi. Oh, who came up with the
idea for Sia to cover unforgettable.
And how did that all come about?
Oh Gosh,
we know who exactly what we,
you always wanted the song.
I just, that was always
said. They gotta have one syllable.
That's the only thing I care about.
Just one. And we don't want to know what
she looks like. Yeah, no, but it was,
the song was always there.
Like you always wanted that song at
the end of the movie and you were new.
We knew it was going to be covered.
Originally we wanted it Robbie Robertson
and Robert said, Robert, it'd be amazing.
Robbie Williams, the head
actually covered, um, beyond
the sea on the first movie.
And so I wanted it to feel like that
same sort of complimentary modern day
singer plus an old classic and see you
pretty much at the top of the list.
We were talking to you
in a session and they said, we need this,
the song is going to be unforgettable.
And um, they said, we're thinking of Sia.
And I got my phone out. She was like,
let's see how fast we can make
this. I said, I'm right now.
And so I texted her and she's like,
are you kidding me?
Of course I would love to do that.
So it was like that quick.
She just was so excited.
So
turns out when you know
islands and generous, you
have to be a friend of Ellen.
And it happened pretty quickly.
I was texting the CEO too.
That's a thing is she was texting with
me when she got that text and I was like,
all right, go. Ellen needs you.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Yeah.
So a couple of things with the
audience too. So what we, uh, uh,
Google also partnered with Pixar and
Disney to basically give you guys a lot of
really cool content, uh,
on the knowledge panel.
If you type in finding
dory on Google search, uh,
you'll see over on the right hand side
in the knowledge panel as a whole bunch
of stuff that Disney has been doing,
trailers and gifts and a whole bunch of
stuff. So it's been really cool stuff.
So thank you guys so much for providing
that. You guys probably didn't know,
but it's there. And so now you
guys know, so check that out.
I'm also a to celebrate finding dory
today being a world oceans day. Um,
everybody, everyone's tuning
in, you know, just to, uh,
help our friends of the sea.
So there's a donate button in the,
in the live stream links you'll see
there. Um, and after this as well, uh,
to the wildlife conservation society.
Oh,
I hope he was literally had
friends at sea. I was friends.
Yeah. Um, uh, to help save rays,
sharks and other wildlife and wild
places across the globe. So, uh, yeah,
it's a great thing Disney is doing.
So if you guys, I looked
that up and so, uh,
what we're going to do here is going to
be something pretty cool and you guys
are all going to be involved.
You guys ready? Alright,
so we're going to take a shell
fee. Yeah, terrible pun. I know.
Um, uh, so as soon as
it yet come on up here.
So what we're gonna do is guys
in your seats, just stand up.
Don't crowd the stage. We're going to
take the cancer going to stand right here.
It in where you fit in.
Anyway.
Alrighty.
Here we go. One, two, three,
everyone crazy space. Here
we go. One, two, three.
Here we go.
Thank you guys so much.
Alrighty. So, uh, so we're
wrapping up here guys.
So finding dory is going to be in
theaters July or June 17th. Uh,
so just a couple of weeks.
So check it out and thank you guys
so much for being here. Let's it.
Okay.
Hey guys, if everyone, uh,
everyone could please stay seated.
We're going to get everyone out here
and so just stay seated for now guys.
Thank you guys so much guys.
We can go.